[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
sarkozy ce matin liona redorer ici
naissent bonjour bonjour arrêts et
bonjour la martinique vous êtes le
président de la fraternité la société
française de secours mutuel du panama
alors nous quel point en français puis
ne connais pas les créoles l'épée
puisqu'on va remonter et mélanger c'est
l'anglais afin de dix minutes chez pucci
ou lan reparler des relations qu'ils n'y
entrent pas la main et puis les antilles
néant shy'm mumbai qui souhaitent y
matinée puis qui sautait guadeloupe pour
construire qu'ils allaient construire
canal panama effectivement et arrêts et
premier wagon a commencé en 1881 avec
les projets de ferdinand de lesseps donc
nous tous savent qui fait du nahd et
l'échec patent ingénieur était un
excellent pour moteur était un excellent
diplomate et ce conseil arrivez à pc le
canal de suez après celle passée était
calme même si même chose là apparemment
ne pas la matinée une chaîne de
montagnes qui cassotti d amérique du sud
comme hôte egis à l'amérique du nord
premier mât deuxièmement nous tenir
chaud et humide shopi call qui est
choqué qu'il a beaucoup des animaux et
des insectes dont il est tombé raide à
six a été blessé au canal à niveau ses
premiers combats étaient terribles des
congrès à paris à l'époque
et puis c'est moi qui avais la pièce et
indienne
angie ne la quittez là c'était moi qui
t'ai jamais météo pied dans l'amérique
centrale pour tisser matinée tiers pour
tisser guadeloupéen quitter
taye au poil et panama parce qu'à un
moment la station grand france et à son
bras diplomatique avait ni pression
canal et youyous et cliquer ici à en
egype donc dit pourquoi pas à devenir
l'eldorado et le moment c'était ça
c'était le panamax était c'était pas si
mal tu me tiens c'était est sentie entre
10 à 15 heures c'est un eldorado
mais oui bien sûr donc a malheureusement
pas potard est la maladie la fièvre
jaune la maladie l'élu parle de malaria
et original au lâchage c'est mal à il
est mauvaise et aux basses qui les a
commencé avec les grands appels pour
fouiller la télé pour pc latella de
tétines et des vapeurs papotant humilité
là et c'est mou la pensée qui les
gravissent plus et ça c'est s'arrêter
car annie aux malades avoué le français
décide et non c'est pas ça y est tu sais
pas sans y penser que ces deux autres
insectes donc été calmes et et les souks
ou avec des lots en pata couche ayo à la
maison dans les casser de l'ouvrier et
un hôpital un peuple ni combien vague
moon qu'apathique on ça
yakiti martinique guadeloupe pour aller
panama combien combien en tirer partie
et si nous garder sur les murs des à la
place de poids saut au panama casco
viejo qui est ouvert qui est mieux la
cap à l'est de 22000 et martinique et
guadeloupe est décédé à mombasa l'épousé
la coulée le fonds ancien adjoint un
caillou et ou quitter nous à s'envoyer
de retourner dans les antilles dont
google apparemment ok trouver et de nos
forces et de nos francophones dans tout
côté jce dans les îles qui sont à dan
dans l'océan pacifique comme agnès était
que comme on essaie d'intégrer couillaud
est ce que ben latifa s'il bat us que ça
est-ce que ça fait quand vous quittez
pays où il va dans le pays et satie
facile le maillot intégré pendant les
pourquoi fouace et il somme qui était
beaucoup plus facile que l'époque
américain ok désir grande vague la
cabine et après 1904 qu'apparemment et
les états unis finissent en poupée et pc
quant à la lutte est une idée vague d un
tiers pour mieux ma c'était des
anglophones moon déjà marie bat batterie
ni d'aller tout ça et après nous
commencé à tenir multi cabinet de la
martinique et de la guadeloupe et la
vague brigade anti francophone suited et
martinique papa tu as acquis passé ici
en 1910 avec alley hoop sur le monde
telle est donc un moment là saint lô
guillaume le cadet nous qui a de la
martinique et de nougatine et vous
pouvez en toi et 5000 moon et la
guadeloupe et c'était et 2000 tony
racisme on comptera six dernières
saisons
bon dieu je tenais au lot à ses emails
parce que c'est moi qui vis ni de la
part de la famille de l'américain pour
pc canal s'est émue du sud des états
unis ça veut dire mon équipe ait existé
la chaleur donc à balai des monnaies à
la bande à tchô jeunes tous ses états à
ciral ça dont les ovnis et jeter nue
possession l'autre manière plus
diplomatique poux et mettez en fosse et
raciaux
donc au lieu des 10 noir blaye audi a6
où ces américains au pays à monnaie des
eaux américaines et ceux cédés aucun
d'autres nationalités plutôt des des
noirs yoka payer en monnaie de l'agent
pas la mer donc tu appelé sa gaule rôle
et silver hall low des gaules d or et de
l'âge avec tijaniya discrimination la
balle a déjà contacté l'aide
et puis et puis à faire ou l'aude beau
est-ce qu'on patinait un moment j'étais
cadiou faute est oublié quant aux
états-unis - panne il est à mon mal à ça
il ya des cas 10 h à quitter qu'à passer
cqib l'enfant n'a met la pâtée vraiment
les activistes suffisante de galhau pas
tabler plus premiers mois deuxièmement
le poison est éteint et panamera qui
étaient là qui venait avec les espagnols
pendant l'époque de la colonisation et
occasion mis ses menaces à céder
étrangers et ce monde là sa cave unis
volet travail à madre opaque à parler
anglais et à côté de ça diop a été aussi
préparé comme les guadeloupéens comme
les antilles ou même union l'histoire
parce que vous-même cassotti affaires
racing grâce au tiguan loupe
pointe à pitre guadeloupe ou complices
et sa une et panama des moments c'était
un guadeloupéen guadeloupéen mener un
panama azad
mais mocassins thibault au moins c'est
toujours la chine envoie c'est toujours
la guadeloupe et la martinique pasky -
néant dans communité des martiniquais et
des guadeloupéens
meetic annoncé omar guèye au panama
sénégal a quitté cassotti donc matinée
que guadeloupe pâtit qu'un parti ne doit
pas l'école
il va tenir les francophones vote était
né doit pas l'école
l'anglophone pas d'étonner doit pas les
patois donc à noter qu'à peine émoussé
nous étape à londres langue qui partait
l'espagnol donc aujourd'hui ça
chagriné - parce que semoun là qu'ils
dégagent intel dit nous des pas les
landes à nos langues maternelles à nous
aujourd'hui
pendant la deuxième langue officielle de
la république ces anglais et timo mayayo
caballé may anglais kitimat maya nous
aujourd'hui
actuellement je lis jouent combien mon
gars qui s'utilise avec hariti en coq
hardi panama en quoi moi qui ai dit
qu'il ya trente et cinquante mille
descendants ont surfé enrichissement des
la république entier ou qu'il trouvait
ça parce qu'ils montrent qu'à multiplier
et pia ou que vous et non francophones
partout à tout coin et autres est fier
d'aider d'origine ayo malheureusement à
papa dans la discrimination raciale
papotage guillotin est interdit de
parler l'anglais yo yo pa ka palé langue
la peau mieux bitonio qui dit ou ce que
oui à mama moins de la maman moi papa -
sortie dé martinique guadeloupe mais pas
qu'à parler l'anglais premier maillot
crédit ou ça vous pouvez parler
l'anglais et sous son nez faut qu'on y
arrive époux pas les cheveux longs et à
la maman mois de jeudi à 4 et boyaux
vous mettez paille et la guadeloupe c
ette pop c'est ma guadeloupe la langue
créole etc la langue des neg'marrons
c'est ça qui ça sert à nous développer
prouver que la pâte et compense avec des
caddies donc toujours été simple mais
comment ces chemins en hommage à l'âge
de 10 à la maison un donc des plumes et
et on travaille des design les moteurs
mais c'était à feu mohamed yacoubi mieux
des cas des cils et la pologne - mais
oui mais c'est ça c'est samuel etienne
alors ou matinik là où passer guadeloupe
avant mais au matinik parce qu'on est en
projet à danville colonnes ok mais blake
oui j'ai eu mon frère veut patiner au
projet nutini au projet je viens dans
l'esprit d ubuntu
au passage si on connaît l'esprit de
ubuntu a expliqué nous ok to boot ou c
est moi point ça des ondes madame black
y arriver un ca de quatrième afrique qui
aujourd'hui the appelle al qaîda c'est
le nom original le nord authentique des
nôtres continental kaboul un rival que
boulogne est bâti mama mon gâteau
des attentes du moment il a mangé gâteau
la tma miles a commencé pour un gâteau
de la et d'essuyer bat tenais à vous
pouvez 9 et 10 autres teams in là et
puis bayonne gâteau la madame la can oui
mais c'est ce qu'affirme le bateau là sa
femme âgée et des noms il dit ubuntu je
suis parti nous tous sommes donc c'est à
nous la foi teny tettini des sièges et
ne-yo la panam aliona colons et nutini
aujourd'hui colo cave qu'à devenir une
zone franche
ce colloque réunit les meilleurs pour
détruire ses polos continuent et la zone
franche la zone moment la zone franche
des colons c'est des animaux et à la
demande sans limite et on limite qui
sent que le monde sorte dehors de
musique les méta colons les maisons de
la caraïbe
ok nous voulait rester toujours en
société le soutien mutuel mais nous
voulons finir on place pour martinique
et guadeloupe et qui sont des
entrepreneurs qui peuvent ni fait des
affaires la est aussi détenu en place
pour appuyer ces mots là pour les juifs
tiny dans toute ville damon les juifs
tenus au casot sociaux youtube et mini
émeute et et à yopougon me new business
a aussi nous son peuple qui vit ni qui
souffre est aujourd'hui panama qu'avec
le boom économique et lé canal de panama
cad donné à l'est et 3h nationale puis 2
milliards de dollars par an pourquoi pas
profiter du sang méthane team à bail en
local est au canada locales aux états
unis au cas aller en france pourquoi pas
venir panama parce qu'il cédait 1,7 à
kibati pays là ça donc nutini doit donc
cabinet impossibilité bas ces
entreprises là ces entreprises ont
développé collet au panama bien sûr le
petit secteur par exemple nous donner
aujourd'hui un boum boum boum dans le
secteur touristique pendant matignon
l'automne ou patiner et heureusement
jusqu'à présent problème d'écrou
chlordécone
donc si vous voulez fait l'agriculture
panama son pays qui a exporté bananes
ananas owens pastèque
mais l'on pourquoi pas vinyle a profité
10 ans nos cafés et les vaches des
poissons ok nutini à
tout type de travail que nous préfet
dernier question mais nous pallions
château ou qu'à travailler by google ads
que tout colle et issia et qui sont
proposés qu'avant mais aller avec le
malade est vite fait aff comme si
j'oublie tiny des contacts et pour
parler des pannes hommage aux sept
touchés affirme que dave car le groupe
brady rapidement mis au monde disait
qu'on pouvait me la laisse pas bon pour
nous les noter et vécu catastrophe là
parce que vous venez à 2005 ont ét é té
ministe et tourisme et le mépris mes
défauts nous n'aimons pas la bienvenue
parce qu'il sait - qui vit ni et
finalement ils tous les droits y a 6
nous nous qu'à ça dommage de ne pas l'y
tranchée de pareto
merci à chailles bonne journée aller
coûte de nos programmes mais si au
niveau éthique aux a été très
intéressante étant kim entre nous